hello everyone and welcome back to the
European Team Championship we are
covering round seven and this is a game
on board one yonas bul of Denmark
against Magnus Carlson of Norway and uh
it's a very very hard for Magnus to uh
to to to play these games and not lose
rating because his opponents are that
much low rated than him some of them
even 300 rating points lower rated than
him okay yonas I believe is the highest
rated player he faced um in the European
Team Championship so far let me just
check uh yeah not not not just the
highest but the only one that is
actually over 2600 and the Magnus did
play him once before I believe five
years ago I I did make a video on it um
I think it was maybe even either a game
or or a short match but Magnus um won
very nicely and uh it would be of course
um very nice for yonas to uh to get his
revenge here as now he is a grandm back
then he was an international master and
he is now I believe 19 years old so
let's check it out quite a wild game and
Magnus chooses a very very weird opening
for such a top level game at the
nimzovich defends to E4 okay let's check
it out yonas has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 and Magnus goes for Knight
to C6 this is the nimich defense and in
terms of popularity it ranks at number
nine so it's the ninth most popular move
after Pawn to E4 uh we have Knight to F3
and now Pawn to D6 the Williams
variation of the nimzovich and now D4 we
have Knight to F6 and Knight to C3 uh
just transposing into the pier defense
we have Pawn to G6 and uh transposing
back into the nimzovich and now Pawn to
D5 we have Knight back to B8 and now
Bishop to E2 we have Bishop to G7 and
both players just castles so castles
castles Pawn to H3 and now Magnus
strikes against the center with Pawn to
C6 we have Pawn to A4 uh Pawn to A5 and
now Rook to E1 o play before before and
now okay Magnus did Retreat his Knight
back to B8 but he played A5 he now wants
to bring his Knight to A6 and then to B4
where it will be very strong it will be
pressuring the C2 pawn and he wants to
play something like develop the bishop
capture here put a rook on C8 and then
the Knight and Rook will be pressuring
that C2 Pawn so very standard stuff much
like you would see let's say in a in in
a dragon Sicilian uh Knight to A6 we
have Bishop to F1 and now Knight to B4
not this Knight maneuver uh but the the
pressure on the C2 Pawn uh we have
Bishop to G5 and now Bishop to D7 and it
is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game and where our game
actually begins uh Queen to D2 and now
Rook to C8 by Magnus and it seems like
you could go for the standard Bishop to
H6 manuver H but this would actually
cost you the game because Magnus would
just play Knight captures and C2 and win
a pawn if you capture the Knight then he
uh takes the bishop on H6 and if you
start with Bishop captures on G7 it
doesn't help because Knight captures on
E1 and and after Bishop captures on f8
Knight captures and F3 comes with check
that's the problem G captures and now
King captures and f8 and you're going to
be down a pawn but that's not your only
um concern as your Pawn structure in
front of your king is also messed up so
it's going to be very easy for black to
attack the white king So after Rook C8
Pawn to G3 was played and now C captures
on D5 e captures and Rook to C5 puts
pressure on that D5 pawn and now Bishop
to E3 attacking The Rook but this is uh
what Magnus was planning he wanted the
the bishop to move back and now he goes
for the standard um sort of Sicilian
exchange sacrifice and that is Rook
captures on C3 uh we have B captures and
now Knight not Knight captures on D5
which is also very much playable but
Knight to E4 first attacking the queen
and going after the C3 pawn queen to C1
and now Knight captures on C3 so what
black definitely has compensation for
the for the sacrificed exchange that's
um uh I mean even just by looking at the
position you can see that uh we have
Bishop to D4 now countering the bishop
and now Knight B captures on D5 we have
Bishop captures on G7 King captures and
Bishop to C4 now uh Pawn to E6 with have
Bishop captures and D5 and now Magnus
plays e captures and D5 as well you
could capture with the Knight this uh
frees up the C Pawn then C4 can be
played and after the Knight moves you
can very very easily grab a hold on that
D5 Square and now it's okay it's a fine
position for white but after e captures
on D5 now it's uh a bit more unbalanced
and you have to figure out how to
continue this with white knight to D4
was played uh the B5 Square does seem
like um a nice Square for the Knight we
have Queen to F6 putting pressure on the
Knight and now Queen to E3 defending we
have Rook to C8 uh and now Rook to A3
now putting pressure on the on the
Knight here so Knight to E4 and now we
have Rook to D1 and and here Magnus has
to decide does he want to capture the
pawn on H3 or does he want to go for
activity he decides to go for activity
he plays Rook to C4 uh and now we have
Knight to E2 offering the C2 Pawn for
the D5 pawn and Magnus goes for it he
plays Rook captures on C2 uh maybe a bit
more precise would be Bishop to C6 you
you defend the pawn and this is still a
threat and there's not all that much um
white can do about that and if something
like paon to F3 attacking the Knight you
you can even play Queen to E5 and attack
the G3 Pawn of course if the pawn
captures Knight then Rook captures you
will win the Knight on E2 and it's just
a much much better position for black
but Magnus uh played Rook captures on C2
right away Rook captures on D5 and now
Knight to C5 now he goes after the A4
pawn and now Knight to D4 attacking The
Rook on C2 so Rook to B2 and now comes
Queen to E1 and now what um what can you
play here uh some pressure is being put
to that A5 Pawn but can you just uh
capture on A4 is that uh is that still
an idea for example if you go just
Knight captures on A4 uh well the
problem is the same as what happened in
the game so I'm not just going to show
it to you because Magnus played Bishop
to C6 and now he missed um a move it's
the exact move that would we would play
If The Pawn on A4 is captured uh feel
free to pause the video and figure out
what Magnus missed while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show uh it is
Rook to F3 a very nasty move where it
seems like you can just move the queen
but where uh there's really no good
Square the only square is d8 and if you
move the queen to d8 then you see what's
happening you can see that the rook and
the King are on the same diagonal and
queen to C3 check will win the Rook on
B2 so we just have to get rid of
everything in between and then our uh
our variation works so we're going to
play Knight captures and C6 with tempo
attack the Queen B captures and now
we're going to play Rook captures on C5
and now okay black is just up a full
Rook or white is just up a full Rook or
if you capture this Rook then you play
Queen not here because then Queen can
block with D4 you have to play Queen to
E5 with check and now you will pick up
that Rook once the king moves doesn't
really matter where Queen captures on B2
and you're going to be up a full Rook so
this is what Magnus missed after this
Rook to F3 move uh so he had to figure
out what else to play and the only way
to continue the game is to play Bishop
captures on D5 he gave up the Queen H
for rook and that um uh piece on D5 so
Rook captures on F6 King captures and
now Knight to F5 even again yonas goes
for this bishop to C3 check he wants to
pick up the Rook uh so King captures on
F5 and now Pawn to G4 with check yonas
says okay now go back to F6 so I can
take the Rook because if you go forward
I'm just going to deliver Checkmate so
doesn't really matter what you do or if
you go to G5 also uh doesn't help Queen
to C1 check will pick up the Rook here
so Magnus goes back King F6 Queen to C3
with check King E6 and now Queen
captures on B2 and now uh Magnus has a
rook a knight and a bishop for a queen
but he's also up to pawns um white is
better question is can white win it so
Bishop to B3 uh putting pressure on the
A4 pawn and now Queen to E2 with check
King D5 we have Queen F3 check King to
E6 and pawn to G5 we have King back to
D7 and pawn to H4 now uh King to C7 by
Magnus and pawn to H5 now we have G
captures on H5 and queen captures now
putting pressure on H7 uh but you don't
have to worry about the G5 Pawn that
much as the bishop here is covering F7
and without eliminating that pawn you
are not creating a pass Pawn you would
have to play F4 F5 and then Advance the
G Pawn so Pawn to B5 Magnus wants to
create a pass Pawn on the queen side for
himself to push a captures on
B5 uh and now King to B6 uh A4 would be
actually a big mistake if you play A4
then Queen F3 is just very nasty there's
no way to avoid Queen to C6 uh and uh
you're not in time to also try anything
else so you have to eliminate this Pawn
uh so instead of pushing King to B6 was
played now comes Queen to E2 or you
capture here but it doesn't really
matter as the pawn defends on F7 Magnus
would just start pushing the a pawn so
Pawn to A4 we have Queen to E8 and now
Pawn to A3 Queen does come to C6 but now
the pawn is already on A3 King to A5 and
now Queen to A8 with check King B4 and
now Pawn to B6 we have A2 and pawn to B7
and now Magnus has to give up the Knight
for the pawn so Knight captures Queen
captures with check and King to C3 and
it seems Magnus is very very close to
winning if he can deliver this A1 Queen
it will come with check he's going to be
up a bishop so completely winning but of
course you will not allow that Queen A7
stops A1 Queen so King to B2 preparing
that and now Queen to D4 with check uh
that's the way to do it we have King to
B1 Queen to E4 check King to B2 and now
Queen to D4 with check King B1 Queen to
E4 with check King to B2 and he was in
this position on move 55 that yonas and
Magnus uh agreed to draw uh is there is
nothing more to be done here if you try
something else like Bishop to C2 also
you can just play Queen to B4 check now
you have to move the king king to C1 and
now you have control of this diagonal
it's going to be a Perpetual just Queen
E1 Queen B4 Queen E1 Queen B4 or if you
try something like Bishop B3 even Queen
to D2 check Bishop blocks you still
continue Queen to B4 check and uh black
can never make any progress here H but
yeah after King to be two they agreed to
a draw and that's all there is but
luckily for Norway on board for um Cen
defeated rasmusen and Norway took the
victory over o over Denmark uh so very
nicely done by unas he almost got his
revenge but yeah even even getting a
nice winning position Like This was um
uh was okay but yeah after Rook to F3
there there was just nothing more to be
done here uh but yeah uh Magnus didn't
just resign and you should not either
when you have a situation like this you
know uh try try to fight two pieces for
a queen it's not a lot uh uh but it can
be done if if you really you know
persevere and if your opponent doesn't
maybe make 100 uh percent of the
position uh you will get your chance and
maybe you will not lose the game like
Magnus did in here uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank the maximite chess club
Jeff markson Derek King Ahmed Al halabi
and David gasparian for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the European
Team Championship until it finishes uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day